hey youtubers is Charlie so there's a
whole bunch of stuff going on in the
Marvel Universe right now robber John
jr. of course made some comments
recently about what's not going on with
Iron Man 4 but the big rumors right now
are that Dave Bautista is going through
some major contract restructuring that
would give him a much bigger part in the
Marvel Universe a lot of people really
big in the Marvel Universe have been
teasing some things and also talked
about that promo art for the vision that
recently leaked also as you may have
noticed I changed things back to the old
way things look I'm in my new apartment
I just haven't set up my new official
set so I'm just gonna make it look like
this temporarily if you're just finding
me for the first time though I do Marvel
videos every week I'm gonna be doing
agents of shield videos whenever that
gets here so please subscribe to get
everything it's gonna be a really fun
season and there's a lot of big Marvel
movie stuff happening so just explain
that Robert Downey jr. stuff real quick
he didn't say that they were absolutely
not doing Iron Man 4 he basically just
said that Marvel left it up to him
Marvel just gave him the power to move
forward with Iron Man 4 or passed the
torch on to a new actor that means he
gets to pick his own successor so the
next Tony Stark that you see will be
cast by Robert Downey jr. himself that
won't happen till way after Avengers 3
so is that gonna be anytime soon right
now Drax the destroyer is the young gun
on the scene so the big teaser is you
know possible Avengers 3 crossover with
the guardians via Trax if you remember
there was actually that scene where
Peter quill said you know earth is
awesome interact said I'll have to go
there someday
that wasn't a tease for this they didn't
know that there was gonna be any kind of
crossover when they made the movie James
Gunn was just leaving room for the
future but James Gunn you know obviously
didn't know the entire Marvel phase 3
plans so he didn't write that
specifically knowing that Drax or anyone
else would get star on any of the other
teams usually whenever first movies like
guardians get made because there's
always the risk that they might flop
they just are written to be a little
more self-contained unlike say Captain
America Winter Soldier which had like
Marvel Universe shattering consequences
that really they kind of shattered the
shield glue that held the Marvel
Universe together I always view shield
is like the connective tissue shield as
well as Samuel Jackson and Phil Coulson
or at least they were the connective
tissue in the phase 1 movies now it's
starting to turn more into the infinity
gems and Thanos
or the infinity quest if you've read the
comic book based on the pacing of the
movie so far it kind of seems like
they're stretching that out all the way
through phase three you know maybe even
longer if you haven't read any of the
comics about the Infinity Gauntlet or
the infinity gems don't worry you still
have a long time to catch up but
eventually everyone's gonna have to come
together to team up against Thanos the
guardians in the Avengers so that's
basically where this Drax crossover
comes in there are a couple things we do
know for sure nothing is happening no
crossover is happening before guardians
to that movie is currently scheduled for
2017 James Gunn's already confirmed that
there will be no more humans on the
teams but there will be a couple female
members space based female members we
can talk about that in a separate
Guardians video tracks is really the
center of the story here so there has to
be a reason for the Guardians to meet up
with the Avengers presumably that's
going to be Drax the story isn't known
yet you know but it's not like both
teams are just gonna meet up for
shawarma on a dime it's like trying to
turn to ocean liners at opposite ends of
the ocean together the easy way into all
this crossover business is just to have
one member cross over to the other team
instead of trying to do all the
characters previously it was rumored
that Hulk was gonna be guest starring in
a future Guardians movie whether or not
that's still the case now it's all about
Marvel reworking Dave Bateses contract
allow him to be in an Avengers movie
they're not restructuring it just so
that he can be in an Avengers movie
they're restructuring it because
guardians was so successful they want to
make him a much bigger part of the
Marvel Universe I know some of you were
wondering if only Drax is gonna get star
and Avengers 3 what does that mean for
an Infinity Gauntlet storyline I know it
might sound like a bummer but they're
probably totally gonna push the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline way past Avengers 3
like somewhere interface for you know at
least indefinitely Marvel still has a
lot of IP it needs to develop like
Inhumans Black Panther Captain Marvel so
they might wait to do Infinity Gauntlet
until after all those characters have
been introduced and that's gonna take
beyond Phase three and then we have to
consider all the infinity gems obviously
they all have to come together for an
Infinity Gauntlet storyline to happen so
far there's still two gems we haven't
seen yet there's the time gem and the
soul gem one possible solution that
would allow them to prolong the Thanos
infinity storyline would be to have all
the gems just trade hands
couple times you know go to a villain go
to another character back to the heroes
and so on like at the end of Thor the
dark world the reality gem aka the
aether is given to the collector imagine
someone steals it from him you know
things like that are probably gonna be
happening over the course of Phase three
and remember not every single movie is
gonna feature a gem another good example
of gems changing hands is Loki's staff
essentially the mine gem it went from
Thanos first to Loki then to the
Avengers then Baron von Strucker and
presumably at the end of age of Ultron
back to the Avengers unless someone else
takes it so the real big question is
what story could they do in Avengers 3
that would require Drax the destroyer
but not the other guardians it's a
little early to speculate given we
haven't seen age of Ultron but I know a
lot of you have asked me about Civil War
being a potential storyline I don't
think that's gonna be the case just
because Winter Soldier borrowed a lot of
elements a lot of DNA from Civil War you
had the thread of superhero on superhero
violence as well as the idea of this big
government conspiracy but usually
sequels do a really good job of
following up on preceding movies with
the next logical step so like Avengers 2
for instance is picking up where Winter
Soldier left off just cleaning up all
the remnants of Hydra around the world
right now we have no idea which movie is
going to be the last movie before
Avengers 3 we do know that ant-man is
gonna pick up after age of Ultron
presumably in the movie Ultron's gonna
create an army of replicants to take
over the world the Avengers will first
have to neutralize him somehow and then
deal with the cleanup again
Joss Whedon is pretty good about
surprising us with a few left turns so
I'm really interested to see where the
team leaves things off before the events
of ant-man pick up really the big T's of
age of Ultron is that the Avengers are
gonna get their asses handed to them I'm
still hoping to see Carol Danvers at the
end of the movie supposedly she might be
featured but they might leave her for
her own movie which presumably would
take place during phase 3 but as of
right now the only confirmed projects in
phase 3 are ant-man which is in the
middle of shooting of course Doctor
Strange which is still trying to lock
down an actor guardians 2 which is in
pre-production that's already greenlit
Avengers 3 which is also in
pre-production and black panther the
other ones that have been teased the
Inhumans movie in the Miss Marvel or
Captain Marvel however you want to think
about it those are also and
development but no word on when we're
gonna hear anything about them but
really the big takeaway from all this is
that Marvel is prepping all these big
movies to handle crossovers you know
have big characters that are already pre
established show up in other people's
films obviously Captain America has
already kind of done that with the
shield characters and if you didn't hear
about it Hawkeye actually totally got
cut out of the movie it was kind of a
bummer for Jeremy Renner but hey I mean
he gets paid a ton of money speaking of
new characters showing up there was
actually some promo art for age of
Ultron that showed up this showed off
the vision as you can see here he pretty
much looks like he does in the comics
you know obviously there are a few
highlights that are a little bit
different but he's gonna be full-on
Android in the movie he's not gonna be
like a robot like he won't have
mechanical parts but there will be a
clear evolution just like we'll see what
Ultron in the movie you know they're not
gonna start out and they're fully
evolved state the other really cool
thing about this is the Avengers tower
in the background the finished Avengers
tower there are a few people missing
from this picture but you get the idea
it's all about the vision and he looks
pretty cool but let me know what do you
think about Drax guest-starring in an
Avengers movie Avengers 3 in particular
and what do you think about the new
vision I actually did a whole big video
about the vision a while ago so you can
click here to learn more about his
origins in the movie universe it's gonna
be different than it is in the comics
and you can also click here to learn
about all the shows and the movies and
stuff that I may be doing videos for
this fall I did a big channel trailer
update thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you